pluie brouillard averse crachin tempéri
appelez-le comme vous voulez le mauvais
temps persiste depuis des mois
parapluies et coupevent ont volé la
vedette au parasol et aux lunettes de
soleil si certains refusent de rallumer
le chauffage d'autres ivelinois s'y sont
résignés et craignent que ce soit leur
portefeuille qui chauffe de toute façon
moi j'ai un chauffage collectif donc oui
il est allumé et voilà j'ai pas le choix
mais tant mieux qu'on on est il y aura
une incidence sur le loyer bah sur les
charges en fin d'année ou oui pas de
problème on y aura le droit aussi je
dirais au moins 100 à 150 € par de plus
pour l'année quoi les livreurs de fi ne
désemplissent pas leur carnet de
commande depuis l'hiver côté
consommation électrique la hausse reste
modérée on a en Île-de-France un
surcroix de consommation électrique qui
est assez modeste qui est de l'ordre de
3 % alors que sur l'ensemble de la
France on serait plutôt à plus 5 % voire
même plus 10 % à certains moment alors
en île-de-fance c'est moindre parce
qu'on est au nord de la Loire où il y a
une influence océanique qui fait fait
que les printemps sont un peu plus frais
de toute façon dans la région parisienne
que dans le sud de la Loire et le
chauffage électrique est plus répandu au
sud également que au nord de la France
comptez tout de même pour votre
prochaine facture une hausse de 10 à 100
€ pour les adeptes du chauffage au gaz
qui connaissent les mêmes difficultés on
note heureusement une prochaine baisse
du prix de 0,6 % le 1er juin les
particuliers ne sont pas les seuls à
trinquer même les administrations sont
concernées la communauté d'agglomération
compa aujourd'hui indique que leurs
radiateurs sont rallumés à minima le
matin une première en
mai